this is going to be a graphic I'll talk
if you couldn't tell from the title it's
gonna be a little bit about graph QL a
little bit about go can I see a show of
hands for who has heard of graph QL okay
who knows what graph QL is okay who's
deployed it okay that's about what I
expected
basically everybody has heard of it most
people don't know what it is and fewer
young people have sort of done something
with it and deployed it and so Who am I
I'm Chris why should you listen to me a
little bit of history
I built the UI team at docker that's
where I was first introduced to go wrote
my first go we're my first open source
code which is great I've been using
graph QL for about two years now ever
since relay was released by Facebook and
a lot of my experience comes from
consulting with smaller startups mostly
in the Bay Area so a lot of the advice
that I given a lot of the things that I
talk about are more ground building
products building products with smaller
teams getting more out of less which is
one of the reasons why I really like
graph QL and if you think about when we
build api's one of the things that I
really want to focus on during this talk
is who are we actually building them for
right because an API by itself doesn't
yield anything an API is a tool for
somebody to build something whether it's
a CLI a GUI web or desktop app could be
a job running and some kubernetes
cluster somewhere but we're building the
api's for somebody to use right so we
can think of them as products in
themselves and what we build with them
with effects how those people can use
them and what they can get done and how
easy they can do it
how much frustration they have to go
through to actually get their work done
day to day right
and sort of the mainstays of api's right
now our rest and GRP see right there's
other technologies like soap there and
not really used anymore
and then there's graph QL which sort of
doesn't replace either of these things
in the grand scheme of things but pulls
them together to offer a much nicer
development experience when developing
against the api's so let's talk a little
bit about rest rest has been around
since around 2000 when y Fielding's
dissertation came out it was popularized
a couple years later 2006 something like
that by Twitter and or piped or and
other companies like that and the thing
that rest is most known for in my mind
is sort of giving rise to conversations
about what true rest is most of the
popular is popularized versions of rest
that people use or a couple gets a
couple posts maybe if you will throw a
couple puts in there and then try to
like explain what a posts gonna put are
to other people that try to use it and
like they don't really get it and then
you're like okay but those are the sort
of the rest deployments that we are
living with right there's this sort of
leveling to rest and nobody really ever
gets to that like glory of rest right
it's always you can build a REST API
with hypermedia and hey Dios and it'll
be this amazing thing and you never have
to learn anything about your server to
use it and nobody really ever gets there
all right
has anybody in this room built one that
uses hideous and hyper media and would
consider themselves to be some kind of
level 4 rest
deployer no hands went up either people
are very hungry or nobody's about it so
yeah so it's basically this arc is like
grandiose architectural concept that has
devolved into people shipping api's that
sort of use HTTP but also just like sort
of ignore most of it right like if you
if you send a get request and you get
look at any of the 200
considered a success right it doesn't
really matter which one you got it's
like a 2x X could be a 4x X or 5x X and
they all they mean like four or five
different things right like and when you
use reskin you deploy a rest api so you
have to start thinking kind of hard
about like the URL structure right it's
supposed to be representational state
transfer so you're supposed to be
thinking about resources and you're
supposed to be you're structuring your
urls such that you have a resource in
the of an ID and you have a sub resource
and you have another ID and sort of
organizing all of these and organizing
all of these in a way that involves
really well is not an easy problem and
people usually skip it like in the real
world people look at this and they go
okay well I need a new snapshot for our
iOS app I'm gonna add a sub URL that is
iOS underscore snapshot and we're gonna
hit that and a little bit more like RPC
than others like rest and then you
combine the two and it's a little bit
you know it's a little bit difficult to
work with so you're sort of tied to http
for rest you're not supposed to be tied
to HTTP for rest but that's how
everybody implements it and if you try
to use all of the HTTP verbs you know
you got your get post post put delete
etc you end up having to explain to
people like what the difference between
put and post are and then they come back
and they like oh but I've read this blog
post and I said that they're actually
not create an update there's this other
thing and you have to have a whole
conversation about that and it just gets
a little confusing right this is one of
my favorite diagrams in pressed world it
is the flow of the decision making
process for the Erlang web machine rest
toolkit and if you want to blow this up
into poster size and read it later I
encourage you to do that it is actually
great read but it just sort of describes
how complicated this start was like
decision-making process is when you're
receiving a rest request and then you
have to sort of like choose what to send
and even if you do this even to you all
of this you still end up in the
situation where the people using it
don't pay attention to any of these like
status codes like you send to get
requests it sends back some 200 kind of
response they're supposed to do
something slightly different they don't
because they're just like I got a 200
I'm moving forward and then there's the
issue of documenting these rest api's
right and swagger came onto the scene
and we moved from sort of like okay we
can write a bunch of markdown we can
describe what the API is maybe we're
using a strongly typed language maybe we
can like somehow try to lean on the
strongly typed language - like generate
documentation or we can sort of like try
to use this weird like type system paste
it on top with swagger and like try to
generate like interactive documentation
on top of that it's not really a great
it's not really a great usability
experience right and even on top of that
after you if you nail your documentation
you still have like core problems with
rest right you get over fetching for
example and some people set up sparse
field sets so that you can select
subfields on a resource but the vast
majority of people do not write it's
that glory of rest thing again it's like
it could be everything you need it to be
it just in practice usually is not and
then we have the same problem it's over
fetching which is like okay I make a
rest request I don't need all 50 fields
that it's gonna send me back I need two
of them right so that's over fetching
under fetching is I send a request it
gives me back the resource and it gives
me back a resource with a field that has
a list of ID's right so it's not really
the information that I wanted I wanted
the field with the list of objects right
I want to I want to go do something with
that stuff I don't want to have to make
and plus one more requests just to get
additional information and you're sort
of lucky if you get IDs right if people
try to go full rest and they try to do
hypermedia you're getting
a list of URLs if you get IDs you can
send an additional request and make it
two of them so the one to get them and
the one to get all of the other IDs if
you have a multi get endpoint right if
you get a list of URLs you either have
to parse that URL and then go try to hit
the other Multi multi get endpoint or
you can send just like the n plus one
request because you have just a like a
list of URLs that you're supposed to go
hit and some people implement sort of
like expand api's right and the query
parameters and you can say like okay I
have a list of T do's and I want you to
actually send me back all the objects
when I query that reduce but that like
that still gets hairy and it sort of
pushes you into architectural styles as
you scale up popularized a little bit by
Netflix right whether it's just like the
back ends for front ends we can't really
define a REST API or we don't in
practice define rest api's that are so
generic that we can use them across iOS
android web desktop like TVs if you're
on them etc etc right CL is they just
end up amalgamating a bunch of extra URL
endpoints that the other ones don't use
and then you end up in this situation
where you want to build a different
back-end for each front-end and that's
not a bad thing right it's just a very
resource-intensive thing like you can
get this done if you build five api's
for each of your UI surfaces but you
have to have the teams to support those
api's and to build them out which isn't
great when then there's G RPC which is
an RPC framework as I'm sure most of you
are aware who's used G RPC in the room
yeah I mean it's a go conference like
that's totally expected the G RPC is
really nice it gives you a lot of nice
things gives you authentication gives
you bi-directional streaming flow
control you can do sync racing
cancellation timeouts you can generate
clients for other languages G RPC is
really useful when you control the whole
stack
if you are trying to build an API
there's going to be used by your clients
you don't really necessarily want to
ship a G RPC API so that they use G RPC
clients to connect to your API right and
then there's the issue of like if you
want to use G RPC everywhere the tooling
just isn't quite there yet right
like G RPC web is around but it's in
beta and it's been a while so it's your
PC has been out and ER PC web is still
in beta ok so if you want like your web
developers to be using G RPC to
communicate with your api's it's not
going to be great for them because
they're already using a binary format
which means you have to write better
documentation because they're not gonna
be able to inspect it to figure it out
or they're gonna have to use additional
other command-line tools to figure out
what they're actually going to get back
and what they can actually call and your
PC web is going to be GA by October so
if that is your path and you are G RPC
everything good luck
so that brings us to the sort of like
graph QL right and why would we want
graph QL I think in Kerala in comparison
to rest is fairly obvious that there are
a lot of pitfalls in practice when
people go to develop these things and we
can make a lot of things much easier but
it's graph QL not to the exclusion of
these other technologies it's graph QL
as the client server gateway on top of
these technologies right we're not using
graph QL for servers to server
communication although people are doing
that
we're saying hey we have this G RPC
back-end micro services infrastructure
it's working really well for us it's
performing we like it it's been around a
while it's been stable but we also like
we need to support new and emerging a UI
surfaces right we need we're developing
this new CLI and it needs to hit our
api's we're developing this new desktop
app and it needs to hit our API and we
don't we don't know that when you start
out right
so graph QL makes evolution of schema
really easy and much more like protocol
buffers than in like rest which is much
much much more ad hoc so when would you
use graph queue all right I just called
it a technology for sort of
client-server interaction and you would
use graph QL if you're trying to build
an API that you consider a product right
if you have a team that is responsible
for managing this gateway that all of
the UI surfaces use and you treat it as
a product that those teams are using to
build out their products then graph QL
is going to be a good thing for you
right if you are fully integrated like
we said before and you have like a
single Java app talking to your G RPC
back-end maybe you just want to stick
with G RPC so graph QL comes with this
really nice property of being typed
right so goes types graph QL is also
typed and that's sort of nicer than the
equivalent of rest world where you can
use a dynamic language and then you have
to sort of layer the swagger typing
system on top and then generate your
automatic documentation graph QL is
built in such a way that you write the
schema first and then you derive your
server from that schema and what that
means is that developer tools can
introspect that schema and hand you
autocomplete in your editor right if you
ever need to query something you can go
into your editor hit a key binding and
figure out the fields that you can query
right which is much nicer than having to
go out to some foreign documentation
server right hitting some HTML page and
trying to figure out like okay there's a
bunch of things here what can I use and
this is an example of one of the tools
that's sort of built on top of this
introspection API on the left you can
see a query a graph QL query to the
right of that is the result of that
graph QL query which is usually JSON and
then this sort of overlay on the right
is the introspected schema of the graph
QL server
so you can this is called grass ql
playground and it comes with one of the
technologies I'm going to talk about
later but you can just sort of click
through this and figure out what fields
you can query what fields they return
which things are required which things
are not required if things are
deprecated they won't show up here and
people won't use them it's a really nice
interactive editing experience and it's
built on top of this core premise that
graph QL is typed and schema based let's
do a brief introduction to graph QL
itself a bunch of people here have heard
of it what is actually graph QL graph QL
is a query language it prioritizes types
as opposed to rasp endpoints like I said
in the last slide it allows you to
develop these dev tools on top of this
introspection API and it helps you do
API evolution in a sort of a baked-in
way right there are these things called
directives that you can use on your
fields when you're defining your graph
ul schema and if you want to decorate a
field all you do is type deprecated next
to it in the schema and then the dev
tools can read that and say okay well
I'm not going to show this to the people
who are just bootstrapping this new UI
on the side and then you have things
like the graph cool playground that I
just showed you which are built on top
of that introspection API and when I say
types over endpoints I'm saying that you
basically have this schema definition
language which behaves a bunch like
protocol buffers if you're familiar with
those that you can say hey here's my
query type here the fields on my query
type and those fields can relate to each
other and those sub fields can relate to
each other and you can query down the
entire tree and select all of the things
that you need by the relays they're
related to each other as opposed to okay
I'm gonna go try to find the iPhone
underscore version 6 snapshot breast
endpoint
so graph QL basically has three things
encapsulate sort of what it is right
there's this way that you describe your
data in the schema definition language
and if you've ever written a go struct
this looks very similar but not the same
right we have a project type it has a
name it's a string it has a tagline is a
string it has some contributors which
are users and user is another object
type somewhere else in the API right
then you ask for what you want
you send a graph QL query graph Gale
queries are roughly JSON objects without
the values right so if you look at this
we have a project and tag line the
project looks a bit like a function call
because it kind of is the things that
you're passing in there are arguments to
the query so in this case we're getting
a project of name graph QL and we're
selecting a field on that query called
tag or tag line so we have the schema
language to define what our data looks
like we have the query language query
that schema and then we have the results
which come back as JSON right so if you
look at this result and you look at the
slide before it which is the query for
the result the structure of the query
and the structure of the result are the
same right so if I go and I'm gonna say
okay what is this result type going to
look like it's going to have a project
key and it's going to have a tag line
key inside of that project key right and
that's exactly what we have and we get
the string out of the tag line so you
get predictable results right you're not
querying with say like sequel and you're
gonna get like nulls when you don't
expect them or something like that right
this isn't a full-fledged database query
language it's a descriptive tree that
you're just sort of traversing down so
with respect to the SDL there are quite
a number of features that can be used in
it but it like I said before it's it's
fairly similar
to writing structs or writing protocol
buffers like you name the fields he
named the type scheme the objects every
bunch of primitives billions floats in
strings this is a technology that grew
up sort of with the intent to be used by
a lot of JavaScript developers so you
get the sort of effects of that type
system right you get float and int
instead of like double right and this is
okay because yeah I mean we have to care
about the people that are using the
api's right and we can define our own
scalars for sure something else you'll
see in this STL declaration right now
our default arguments so if you look at
the users inside of the fruit object you
have a limit which defaults to an int of
10 right and then the exclamation points
are whether things are required or not
so let's talk a little bit about a
specific technology in the go ecosystem
that we can use to implement and deploy
graph QL servers in this case we're
going to talk about gql gen gql gen is a
schema first type safe code gen based
toolkit for building graph QL servers
you define your API using the schemas
that we just looked at we looked at a
couple examples type safe means you're
never gonna see map string to interface
right this is a well typed language onto
another well type language so we're
going to merge those together right
we're never going to lose type safety
because we're using graph QL and then
the code Jinna sort of like okay there's
a lot of code that we could write
there's a lot of code because we have to
type systems here that we can just
generate and map from one to the other
so we're gonna do that as much as
possible and the way you use this is you
know just like any other go live you go
get it which I hope somebody thought
about go get when I created that command
because it fits really well in sentences
you're gonna write the schema in this
case it's going to be a simple to do app
I've got it to do type all the fields
are required the ID that you see there
is just a string it's a special special
scalar and then yeah we've got users and
we've got the query type the root query
type is basically your entry point into
a graph QL schema so if you were going
to query this schema you would query to
dues and then you could sub select on
the jew's users but there's no other
entry point into this schema there's
also a mutation types so you don't just
ask for stuff and get it you say put
this new stuff into the system and you
get results back out so in this case we
have an input type which is the same as
the type declaration before very similar
to structs got new to do with a text and
the user ID both required the mutation
is the same thing as the query type
before is the entry point into how do
you create things in this system in this
case we have create to do it takes the
input type that we specified before and
returns a to do and then we create sort
of our database models right so it's
very likely that you already have a
server somewhere that you're doing
something with that has some models for
your business use case right you're
getting something from a database
somewhere you have this model somewhere
you can use that and you can map it to
the schema in the graph QL world so you
don't have to throw out any of the code
that you already wrote for interacting
with databases and things like that and
if this is G RPC you can use the
protocol buffer definitions here cetera
this is a llamó file so like I said
before in the models you can map models
to graph QL schemas if you want to do
this manually you can do it like this if
you do not put an entry here and you do
not have a model for it one of the nice
things that gql Jen will do for you is
it will generate that type so you'll
notice when we look at the
a couple of the next slides this input
new to do type is not declared in our
llamo file because we didn't write it
like we don't really care about it it's
just a thing that says hey we're gonna
accept these two fields and then we
gonna create you a to do but like we
don't really care about any of that
mechanical stuff and then generates two
files for us one of them is a model file
and one of them is a graph file just to
run gql gen you can stick this and go
generate so you can run go generate
instead of running gql Gendron overall
and the files that it gives us there's a
graph file on the models file this is
the graph file this is a extremely
truncated version of the graph file that
we just generated and it basically
allows us to create a new executable
schema so we've got the schema we need
to turn it into a server that we can run
stuff against the way that graph QL
server is usually work or they have a
parse stage a validation stage an
execution stage so we need to turn this
schema into something that we can
execute against you get this resolver
root interface and that's important
because we need to write resolvers for
our graph QL schema if somebody asks us
for a list of to Do's resolvers are the
way that we say this is how you get it
to do this is how you get a list of to
Do's and then as you can see here we've
automated this input type new to do
right it comes with the JSON tags comes
with the struct etc in this case was
fairly simple so it's simple and then
like I said before we have to set up the
resolvers to actually get the data back
to the client after it's asked for in
this case we're setting up a simple AB
struct to hold some to dues this would
be like your database or whatever if you
actually had a real application we're
using an abstract for demo purposes and
this code will be up on github later if
you want to go look at it I'll tweet it
out so we have the top-level resolver
types
mutation to do query query mutation are
the ones that you typically think of
this top level in the graph QL world
they are the entry points to getting
data and mutating data and then we've
got a query resolver for our query type
in this case we're just returning the
list from our abstract right but this
can easily be any sequel query this can
be an RPC call this could be anything
that you need to do with the information
that you're given to go get that stuff
and then return it to the user and this
sort of context context input parameter
is where you get a lot more of the
lower-level more advanced use case kind
of things for graph QL right so there's
these things called selection sets it's
basically a fancy word for all the keys
that you specify when you're going to
make a query if I query to do than to
dues is in my selection set for that
level and you can get all at all of that
information through the context there's
a mutation resolver when you send us a
new to do through the graph QL interface
this is where we put that new to-do into
the database and then return the to do
right
like I said app is currently being used
as a database so this is fairly simple
we just create the need to do we append
it and then we send it back
and then we got our graph heal server
right so we can just sort of mount this
in any HTTP framework that we want to
use you can use gorilla mutts here you
could use just HTTP package wherever you
want really in this case there are two
handlers one of them will serve the
graph QL playground that we looked at
before with all the introspection
abilities and things like that it's just
a simple web app and then the other one
is the one that you actually send graph
QL strings to to get the JSON data back
so when we run that server that we just
created we can run a query like this
right so we say query which is a keyword
in graph QL we name that query we're
naming it fine to dues in this case and
then everything below that is a us
delving into the tree asking for
specific fields back and the fact that
you have to ask for specific fields back
is really nice because you're going to
have a bunch of clients at some point
right
maybe you're shipping native apps maybe
you're shipping Android or iOS apps and
not just web apps and not just whatever
is right and not just like jobs that you
run in house if you ship the if you ship
an API for a native app those native
apps never go away and like never is
okay whatever
maybe on some extended time period they
go away but they're not going away any
time soon
so if you make breaking changes these
will break clients in the future right
one of the really nice things about the
way that graph QL handles this schema
and the way that you evolve that schema
is that when people make these queries
you can track those on the server and
you know exactly which fields they're
using so if the old clients start to die
off and nobody's actually asking for
this field anymore you'll know that and
then you can remove it from the schema
and gql gen is sort of about to hit 0.4
so there's a bunch of changes that have
been happening recently it just got
corporate sponsorship so thanks to
99designs for doing that
[Music]
the location of the repo is changing it
just became combative all so 0.4 is
compatible with the June 2018 graph ul
spec it introduces a couple directives
skip and limit which are really useful
directives are sort of like the anything
else of graph QL world right you can
define your own directives you can use
the built-in directives anything that
you want to do that the graph QL world
doesn't already have an answer for you
can write your own directive put it in
the schema and then it'll just work for
you and then there's an init to do some
project scaffolding and you can generate
those resolver stubs so instead of
having to manually write out all the
resolver stuff that we just did we can
get a stubbed-out there's a plug-in
system coming in which means that you'll
have a directive that can indicate that
something is a gr PC field or a gr PC
resolver and just call the G RPC calls
for you from your other declarations so
we have a couple minutes here I'm going
to go over one or two extras before
going into Q&A some things that come up
when you're building graph QL servers
are that you can generate a lot of
sequel calls against your database so if
you build a graph QL server you write a
schema you write some resolvers that
query directly against the database
instead of doing like a rest call or G
RPC call you can end up with a lot of
sequel calls that you write them naively
if you run the graph QL query on the top
of this slide with the resolver on the
bottom of this slide you will end up
with n plus 1 calls against your
database right so you have taken the
problem from being n plus 1 on the
client take an ownership of that problem
and now it's a server problem right so
now instead of worrying about the
bandwidth of 100 API calls from the
client we now worry about the attack on
our database of a hundred or a thousand
that's depending on how many users you
have at any given time right and the way
that you solve this is by
using this concept of libraries called
data loaders and go has one called a
load in which will auto-generate you
data loaders that will handle things
like caching these values will handle
things like weighting a specified time
out like a couple of milliseconds to see
how many users you're actually going to
query for and then you can rewrite this
resolver to instead of select a single
user select a whole bunch of users right
so now you've code gen this cache for
you
so this per request cache and you can
use that to reduce the number of queries
that are being made to your G or PC
server or your sequel database from n
plus 1 to 2 it's a little bit of extra
work but generally is worth it and then
if you want to query against graph QL
servers in go there is the library that
was so nicely mentioned at the beginning
of the talk and that is it for the talk
happy to take questions
ok we've got some time for some
questions so I'm gonna be running around
cuz Matz supposedly got a bad ankle
we'll talk about that later
so yeah let's start over here right here
first question have you used graph can't
go the graph go go library yeah I've
used it yeah so the thing that I like
about gql Jen is that it's schema first
right so if you want to build your graph
QL server and you only want to handle go
code and you don't want to worry about
the schema really then yeah ok graph QL
go could be a better choice the way that
we build graph ul servers in the wider
ecosystem though means that if you build
it schema first you can take some graph
to L server that say like you had some
front-end team that was like we can't
wait for you to absolute like we can't
wait we're gonna go build the server
ourselves they're going to be using
schema first which means
you can take their schema pull it into
your code if you're using gql gen
generate your resolvers and then all you
have to do is write the resolvers don't
have to worry about matching schemas
right
what's the disadvantages of using this
in a micro services architecture so
internally between server to server
server to server it's just me right now
right you were if you use it for
server-to-server communication you will
run into problems that other people
might not have run into yet and you will
have to solve them yourself people
really aren't doing a lot of server to
server graph QL communication yet it's
not that it is something that will never
happen but it's just not widely used so
you're gonna be more on your own here we
have another question over here Chris
yeah are they any good techniques to
protect against kind of malicious actors
I guess yeah so I mean there's a bunch
of different ways you can do this right
there's the authentication is still
going to work the way that you haven't
worked normally right so however you
have your authentication set up for rest
also works for a graphic you all right
you just pass down your authorizations
through the contacts and you're fine and
then the other thing is sort of like if
you are shipping something and you don't
want people to be able to do arbitrary
queries against the server even if
they're authenticated right you can do
use this technology called persistent
queries which is basically in the build
environment or CI or whatever right you
have your UI client basically collect
all the things that it's going to send
to the server it sends them to the
server the server says ok I'm going to
give this an ID I'm going to give that
an idea I'm gonna give that an ID and
then the only thing with the UI sends us
IDs and variables up as opposed to full
queries so you can actually restrict
what's possible both from that
perspective and you can also restrict
sort of like how deep people are allowed
to go in their queries from the server
side how do you monitor
- like observability like logs around
graph QL queries to know exactly like oh
this is the kind of query that is
typical or this is a typical one yeah so
the sort of bleeding edge of monitoring
and observability tools for crafted well
are being built by a company called
Apollo right now they have the Apollo
engine and if you match that spec which
was sort of like included in data loader
or gql gen and things like that then you
can just send the data over them they
have a really nice UI where you view all
that and stuff right you graphs and
things like that they also have another
a nice number of features in addition to
that in terms of persisted queries and
some of the things like that
hey so there are many upsides of using
this over traditional rest but what are
some frustrations or disadvantages that
you've seen so far with graph Cal its
new so you're gonna have to learn stuff
right you're gonna run into problems and
you're not gonna know how to fix them
immediately you're going to have to have
the thought process of ok I have this
graph QL server but it's not it doesn't
have any authentication how do I handle
the authentication you're gonna have to
go through all of those steps and then
figure out how to actually deploy it to
production right ok we have time for
just one last question here what's the
way of like automatically generating the
code from the schema or it's just like
every time you changed it you make a
change in in schema you're just manually
generating the files yeah so basically I
like to think of these things as schema
first so you do your graph QL schema
changes first then you will do the
manual step of sort of generating
additional code and that can be
additional code or not a replacement
code if that makes sense but yeah so
schema first generate to go and then
write any additional things that you
need okay thank you very much Chris that
was awesome
you